I never really wanted to be a scientist,
but I got very interested in physics
when I was about 15.
Uh,
I had quit school when I was 13 and,
uh,
I just somehow got interested in physics
and uh,
and then I just thought I'd studied for
awhile until I could do something else.
And uh,
just things happened in such a way that,
that never happened.
Well,
you know,
I wanted to be an editor for fiction or
a filmmaker,
uh,
or a great writer or a jazz musician
that wasn't really smart enough to be
any of those things.
Unfortunately.
Uh,
you know,
the thing about particle physics is
that,
uh,
it's very intellectually alluring and
then you're,
you get to do a lot of really fun things
in it.
Like you get to build huge experiments
and you actually do it yourself.
So you get to drive forklifts and you
get to work with flammable gases and
explosive things and you get to drill
things and,
and at the same time,
you get to think about,
um,
you know,
quantum mechanics and philosophical
things.
And you get to do write computer code.
You have to do a lot of things that are
very,
very fun and you don't normally get to
do them in life.
Usually you just like move into an
apartment.
It's already made and then you just cook
dinner.
I mean,
that's it.
In this case started.
You get to build the whole thing and uh,
you know,
wire it and do everything does that.
And that may not make any sense,
but you really get to do a lot of fun
things.
And I guess that sort of kept me,
kept me in it.